on the fight against covid we could be
seeing a new oral treatment for the for
the disease coming from the
pharmaceutical company merck which says
it has an experimental pill that can
significantly reduce the effects of the
virus so for more on this let's bring in
our dr david agus dr aegis good morning
to you according to merck the trial was
so successful they had to stop it early
to get it out there into the public eye
uh what more can you tell us about it
so this is a drug called molnu piravir a
name that kind of rolls off the tongue
earlier had been tried in hospitalized
patients and failed and now in people
with low to moderate uh uh
complex uh cova 19 so symptomatic who
had a complication or potential for
serious complications they were given
twice a day multnopera and dramatically
by 50 percent reduce hospitalization
and death so an oral pill that works
against coven 19 hospitalization
dr how does this compare to uh antiviral
or antibody treatments which are the
current state of the of practice
well tony it is very similar to the
results with monoclonal antibodies the
difference here is that it's an oral
pill rather than an intravenous or a
shot in the arm so it makes it much
easier you can give a patient with mild
symptoms this pill and say go home and
then they will
moderate significantly reduce
hospitalization so this is a big step
forward certainly the hope is you can
use it even earlier if you have covet 19
you give it to your spouse to prevent
them from getting sick that data are not
available yet but this is a big step
forward we hoped it was even more
dramatic but this is pretty good data dr
aegis you said that they could use it
earlier and this is a big step forward
but what does it mean for the fight
against covet right now
so right now this will be submitted to
the fda and by the end of the year will
hopefully be available merck will have
10 million doses of this
completed by the end of the year so this
is something that in the war on covid
can start to be used right now and as
soon as it's fda approved we can start
to prescribe it to patients rather than
them having to come into an emergency
room and be given intravenous therapy of
an antibody or a shot of an antibody
they can get a pill and so this
certainly makes it much easier to treat
and in the end we'll probably save many
lives
dr david agus thank you so much for
joining our show early